this next story is really cool too I'm
also a shack fan right it is a Gala so
big only Shaq could host that's right we
caught up with the Hall of Famer about
this year's big event
Shaq is back the Shaquille O'Neal
foundation's biggest fundraiser the
event presented by Pepsi stronger
together returns to Sin City
having fun
here's some money do a lot of things all
the proceeds to go to through children
last year's star-studded event featured
Justin Bieber Kelly Clarkson Snoop Dogg
and Vegas's very own Imagine Dragons and
Jimmy Kimmel and this year's lineup will
be no different so we're doing part two
on October 1st our NGM Grand we're gonna
have Maroon 5 John Malay and Marin
Morris uh with a few more names to be
announced the event raised nearly 3
million dollars for the foundation which
helps underserved youth mainly here in
Vegas and the Atlanta area in 2021 the
four-time NBA champion renovated the
basketball courts at the Doolittle
complex and handed out hundreds of
backpacks at his Shack to school event
partnering with two organizations very
close to the star's heart communities
and schools and the boys and girls club
you know for me growing up able to go to
the Boys and Girls Club of the Safe
Haven from a rough area there I was able
to cultivate the character you know a
check
I'm going to music room and think I was
a rapper go play basketball when I
wasn't doing good in school I'd have to
go and
fill my homework with the you know
tutoring session kids where I come from
can't afford computers so
I'm doing a lot of money Boys and Girls
Club we built the first Technology
Center in the same club that I grew up
in in Newark New Jersey so definitely
means a lot to me the NBA Hall of Famer
built his own Boys and Girls Club in
Georgia just last year and Uncle Shaq as
the kids lovingly Collins is betting big
on Vegas with a new top secret facility
we're doing a project so big here in
Vegas it's going to be
I can't say I'm so sorry
that was funny I love that all right so
we don't know much more about the new
project but we can't tell you you can
read lips and could you no okay we can't
tell you concert tickets for the event
on October 1st start at 50 bucks they go
on sale tomorrow on
axs.com it's gonna be good